avec francine weecksteen nous attend
cette fois ci on l'a on parlait de marie
louise fort de la situation d'arrêt du
sort qui arriverait en tête on est
arrivés francine weecksteen réactions
sur votre corps vous un sens bonsoir
bonsoir bah écoute et effectivement je
suis assez satisfaite du score qui a été
fait sur pour la première fois à sens
avec une liste sans étiquette politique
une liste qui a voulu rassembler au delà
des clivages politiques classiques
droite gauche gauche et effectivement je
compte rassembler encore plus largement
la semaine prochaine pour effectivement
que ce projet sans étiquette politique
basée sur l'intérêt général puisse
émerger sur sens des retours de l'émir
melun bonsoir francine weecksteen vous
vous avez appartenu à la municipalité
précédente on voit qu'il ya quand même
dans les urnes une forme de sanction
pour pour tous les gens qui ont
participé plus un front national très
élevé et très particulière cette
situation de cette situation sans cesse
que finalement vous aviez des chances
après tout ce qui s'était passé
a coûté la preuve en est que j'avais des
chances puisque j'ai mobilisé quand même
près de 15% des ces données sur ce
projet donc oui
effectivement je pense que pour l'avoir
vécu depuis presque six mois nous savons
rassembler nous avons rassemblé autour
d'un projet un projet d'intérêt général
et c'est ce qui est le plus important
pour moi aujourd'hui pour le deuxième
tour francine weecksteen est-ce que vous
avez déjà réfléchi à ce qui va se passer
on sait que le front national arrive en
deuxième position derrière marie louise
fort est ce que vous allez donner des
consignes de vote est ce que vous
souhaitez vous maintenir quelle est
votre position
je vais me maintenir au deuxième tour
évidemment et je vais rassembler
largement à l'est aussi au devant des
personnes qui se sont abstenus puisqu'il
ya presque 50 % des ces données qui
n'ont pas voté aujourd'hui je pense que
c'est aussi en réaction avec les
différentes affaires ps ump que l'on
peut
voir au niveau national je crois que par
les deux sens avec quelqu'un qui vit à
100 ce qui travailla sens je pense que
ça séduira à mon avis c'est ces
personnes qui n'ont plus envie forcément
d'un projet très partisan